This work is able to simulate an ecosystem with
up to 500,000 plants for 500 years. Buckle up
Fellow Scholars, because we are going to see
simulations with tipping points, deforestation,
Yosemite valley, and the story of shrubs and
pines. Yes we are in for a ride with this paper.
This simulation goes down to the
level of individual branches.
Awesome. And this can simulate cloud
formations too. And it gets better,
it also simulates how the
ecosystem responds to it.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Now, we know that a good simulation paper
has to be able to give us interesting
insights about the world around us.
Does this do that? Well, look. First,
we see clouds everywhere above the
rainforest. Now, unfortunately,
here comes a little deforestation, this is just
a simulation, no real trees were harmed at all,
and look, the clouds disappeared! And, when the
forest slowly grows back, see? The clouds come
back too. Why is that? Because of transpiration.
This means that rainforests release water vapor
into the atmosphere. The trees sweat, if
you will. Now, this vapor rises, cools,
and condenses into clouds. As we have deforested
this region, we have disrupted this beautiful
dance, and thus, no more clouds. And this paper
can simulate all of these phenomena. Love it.
Now, let’s have a more drastic experiment.
Here you see how this virtual ecosystem
reacts to decreasing precipitation.
In other words, what would happen if
there would be less and less rain. Things
are going as we expect them to go - new,
different kinds of species arise that
can thrive in this kind of climate…and
wait what? Uh oh… what is happening? Well, Fellow
Scholars, this is the effect of the tipping point,
this means that the effect of some changes is
predictable up until a point, and after that,
unpredictable, and often catastrophic changes
happen. And these are often irreversible.
Now a slow drought commences, and look
at the patterns in which this shrub land
slowly recedes. Why slowly? Because
they are really good at adapting to
the new conditions…until a
point, of course. However,
when we do the same thing faster, rain is gone
quicker, the patterns are suddenly clumpier.
And if we do the slow drought simulation with
pine trees, you remember from a previous episode
how they grow their roots, now these are not so
good at adapting to the new conditions, so even
in the case of the slow drought, let’s see… yes,
they disappear in clumps. Oof. Now I know what you
are looking for, how can the pine trees deal with
a fast drought. Unfortunately, they do even worse.
And now, hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because now we are going to do both and see what
happens. Add shrubs and pine trees at the same
time. This is a simulation after all. We can
do whatever we want here. And…look at that!
The two species cooperate and compete at the
same time, forming these beautiful striped
patterns that would not appear otherwise.
So, in such a simulation paper, we always ask,
this sure looks nice, but is this all for show,
or is this what would really happen in reality?
Well, look at this. Here are the patterns that
emerge in theoretical results in these cases,
and here is the simulation. Wow. Feast your
eyes upon this incredible agreement. And
it gets even better. When leaving theory
behind, and comparing to real photos in
real-world places, wow. I am out of words.
And we have two more experiments. First
is simulating how microclimates emerge.
This is a multi-species simulation where we get
species taking place right at the center of the
formation. These folks love a wet climate.
But not everyone does. These species like a
dryer weather. Let’s remove both of them.
This corridor then regrows these species,
showcasing the famous forest edge effect
where different species carve out their
niches, responding to the subtle
changes in light and moisture.
And now, if you allow me to, I could not
resist this one. In the shadow of Yosemite's
majestic Half Dome, a thick forest of
pines whispers of nature's intricate
dance. As we toy with the vapor in the air,
mimicking the breath of a changing climate,
the trees form curious ribbon-like
patterns across the terrain. But
suspense hangs in the air; this lush tableau
is on borrowed time as the forest withers,
leaving behind a haunting, arid landscape with
only the hardiest of trees clinging to life.
This is a beautiful, utterly fantastic
paper with lots of gorgeous results.
Make sure to have a look at the paper
in the video description, and if you do,
you are not only fulfilling your Holy Duty
as a good Fellow Scholar, but you’ll get to
know more about how to simulate the classic
water cycle, how transpiration takes place,
how trees sweat if you will, vegetation modeling,
soil modeling, weather modeling, you name it.
And now, you know what’s coming. This
is coming. This is a magical paper,
and only about 400 Fellow Scholars seem to have
read it before this video. And this is why Two
Minute Papers exists, to give a voice to these
researchers and show to the world how amazing
these papers are. That is my quest. And thank
you so much for coming with me. I absolutely
love my job doing this. If you enjoy this too,
consider subscribing and hitting the bell icon.